okay four people joining this live
stream this is over the last of our
current series of meetings about image
and signal processing functionality for
the next version of wolf language so
what is this first thing here sorting
function
why is Jose suggesting renaming this so
the function in sort or sort by is
called the ordering function and this is
remember this is the option we are
introducing for now for face recognized
it works like sort by is that correct
it works like sort by yes well what
would you call the function I mean it in
other words if it was going to be called
something I mean another possibility
would be sort ordering function where is
that wrong because we already have a
thing called ordering which does
something I think ordering is the thing
that returns minus 1 0 & 1 so that would
be really wrong it really is well what
is it in sort by what is the I don't
know if it has a name let's look at
there see I'm saying we know
giving it a name because by the way
something is wrong here there's there's
a space that's come out after the that
started to happen in places like that
um there's some bug there this is a
recent issue I'll send it to new dogs
okay sorry
um okay so well what would it be I mean
this is it's kind of like a ranking
function some kind of making sense I
don't think it's obviously wrong to call
it a sorting function I don't think so
hater fine I mean if sorting function
ends up being also an option to sort
that's the buy type function yeah it
says an ordering function there so we
haven't called it a sorting function so
I think that's fine okay I I think we
should in ILD we should discuss where
the sorting function wants to become an
option to some things like sort itself
makes sense
sure can somebody is somebody able to
take that as a note yeah I'm taking some
notes all set anymore okay great
one thing that Jose was suggesting is
that like in the case of fine phases one
reason why we need sorting function is
that the result may not include all the
properties that we may want to sort by
like the age may not come back as the
result and who's ever suggesting
functions that do return all the
properties needed for sorting should not
be extended extended to have a sorting
function but for anything else it makes
sense to have this optional wait a
minute even if it returns all that stuff
it doesn't mean that we know do we want
youngest first oldest first whatever
right right
I think this is but at the same time you
could say it's just a sort by function
around the result and that was his
argument oh I see well that's not an
unreasonable argument I don't think this
hurts anything color neighborhood so
color neighborhood
it's essentially an interval in color
space right except it isn't an interval
yes it's a neighborhood really or a
region little disc in LA B yes not in
all other spaces okay color neighborhood
is such a weird name what else do we
have that's a neighborhood function
nothing um what are some synonyms for
that what else what would this be
mathematically called
any ideas for that no region really no
no but it's a specific region it's a
region that has you know it's a disc
actually in some space correct right
what about color space disk color space
do we use color space do we have
something where we have a color name
color space we typically spell it with
capital s in fact a color space disk no
it's it's it's an ellipsoid isn't it yes
no it has a maximum distance it's a dis
single distance D that's what I would
call a disc yeah but the minute you
change color space you know so you can
say so what are things are nearby colors
it's nearby in one space but it's not so
near it's it's you know it might look
like a disc in one space but it's not in
another space no I understand that but
I'm saying other it's still the same
region of colors but you have to say
what space it's a I mean or is it always
in one particular space can you specify
a different color space here
you can write you can specify different
distance functions yes I don't know what
shapes they are okay but why is this the
debt why is it called a distance
function here because a distance
function actually has to be something
that you can apply to two values to get
back the distance between them right
that's the last entry of the list F a
function that is C ie
76 isn't that right I mean it will be
color distance all right it's color
distance of you know red comma blue that
will give something but color distance
of that and then CIE 76 this function
CRE 76 Y color distance should not it
not taking a distance function like a
distance function is something which
when applied to two values you can't
apply the string CIE 76 right right so
that can be specified as a distance
function setting but it shouldn't be
what why is that working what is that
what is the full functional form of
distance function Arrow CIE 76 we don't
have it
but a small point you want something or
something yes you can as a shorthand say
distance function arrow CIE 76 but it
has to have some actual full form like
this surely we should have that that
wouldn't hurt for us to have there would
be a good thing to have right I mean but
I'm just saying that these are you know
these these are kind of nonlinear
transforms from from RGB space if you're
used to that and I understand that but
why but when you say color color space
disk okay
of red for example let's try color
neighborhood I have got a prototype
build right if I say color neighborhood
of red for example
this will only start up I'll come on
hello great application not responding
okay we have somebody here could report
that what do I have to I'll report it
yeah I'm dead in the water here okay
let's try
oh I don't know after I told it to quit
it came up let's try the mathematical
build see if we have the same problem no
one looked better okay
okay so I say color neighborhood I'll
come on what's it doing
by the way that pull down against
something it should be reported the
middle of that pull down should be that
pull down should come up as I mean that
new pull down should have the 100% in
the middle I'll report this okay
um okay all right
so here color neighborhood of red does
have a default what is that doing does
it have a default some region size what
is it doing here it does have a default
region region size and distance function
but it doesn't evaluate to anything it's
just a wrapper it's just a symbolic
representation of that neighborhood why
doesn't that work it should eventually
that's something we thought about okay
but so how do I get the picture
um oh boy somebody on our live stream is
pointing out that distance function
already has the inconsistency because
image distance also doesn't correctly
deal with yeah this is wrong I mean this
is just wrong this should never been set
up this way that apparently image
distance also does it like that which is
wrong mm-hmm okay so all of you think
that one as well should just take the
distance measure as a third argument I
do yes I do
and if you want to give it a distance
function it can you know you can use the
whole thing or you can do whatever you
want one over image distance or whatever
if you really want that to be the
distance function right so color
distance is just supporting two argument
form image distance already uses third
and fourth argument form as some
alignment positions this was a mistake
see that is fine oh if it's a Euclidean
distance as in yeah Euclidean distance
is fine because it's a fun but this may
be the way we're confused here
this is the right form right because
that wait a minute there should be a
function right it should always have a
function as the right-hand side right
here what's happening here the following
distance so we have some string settings
oh gosh that define basically predefined
functions that are not already system
defined functions oh why aren't they
system defined distance functions we got
a whole zoo of system defined distance
functions why aren't these useful
functions I guess not all of them have
used in other places some of them may
have I guess me nuclear Ian's distances
there's an example of one that can be
which ones cannot be you know well we
can go through this and see how many oh
let's go through it okay I mean look I
we can get away with some strings like
this speed but but they really should
have a full functional form growl I
didn't notice that before oh dear dear
dear okay all right let's not compound
the mistake here numb I'm gonna come
back to saying I like color space disk I
think it's very clear what that means so
long as you say what the color space is
and there's you know that can perfectly
well be a default color space in which
the thing as a disk okay so I mean color
spaces are 3d right it's so you think a
disk is a 3d thing no I'm just saying
just no no no I mean you're right but
this thing is in fact a 3d thing correct
yeah okay all right I'm wrong about that
disk thing so I mean it would have to be
color space ball which is then getting
very very bizarre and word ones thinking
of you know colored balls and weird
nonsense like that
so that doesn't I agree color space ball
is crazy um I don't like color
neighborhood I don't know I can't tell
you okay let's keep going I mean what is
it in fact it's a ball correct in a
certain space true yes yes okay so let's
try to understand what some other things
that are like that might be okay um do
you have suggestions so it seems
reasonable if then this gets extended to
support arbitrary shapes for rather than
just a distance function the only
downside to that is there's no
properties that region has okay jaren
saying yeah it's the right name but it's
it is it's not the right name in the
context of Wolfram language lacy okay so
I mean there's words like lo call and
vicinity I don't think that makes sense
lo call tends to suggest some
internationalization thing it seems to
too colorful
it was another suggestion name was color
mask
know that that reminds me of some bandit
or something I mean I don't know
okay let's look again at how this is
used
okay so it is in effect a way to select
a piece of an image by color whoa wait
wait a minute what on earth is this form
here what on earth is this which form
this one here what is this oh sorry
friend of yours what is that I mean
that's a completely different thing
right right so this is makes no sense
this makes sense right that the the you
know but then color masks may make sense
yeah but that's a different function
this whatever is doing this has nothing
to do with this right right we've
discussed separating that syntax from
color neighborhood well good because
it's the right thing to do I mean this
is something completely different
what what is this even doing this is
this is just saying give me a color mask
that give me a mask based on that color
right right right
the default distance and the distance
function and so forth so not just that
blue I understand I got it right so I
mean it's the in some sense you could
say you could have a thing that says you
know I mean this would really be it's
like edge detect its color detect isn't
it yeah it can be non-binary can be a
grayscale mask okay you have some
smoothing parameter is in color
neighborhood okay fine but so
fundamentally its color detect right in
principle you could have a single color
there mm-hmm right but you could also
say color detect of you know color
neighborhood or whatever it's called
mm-hm of that yep I mean that first
thing would be useful I think because
there are cases that we've even you know
I've even used where you just use a
color a very specific color as a way to
as kind of a hack for how to represent
let's say missing data in a picture or
something right right so isn't the right
form color detect I like it okay so that
we've got to solve the problem of what
is the name for the thing that
represents a you know I mean is it
colors around the problem is we're using
around in our very specific sense for
this perversion which has an around in
it oh that's my version wasn't around
and I hope yeah so I mean this is you
know that's that around mmm-hmm okay
which is not a hard-edged thing that is
a you know that's a that's a mushy edged
you know uncertainty around replace is
that also something I have it in my
prototype field yeah around replace is a
thing that has to do with the
complexities of dealing with whether
errors are correlated or not
uh-huh it's kind of clever actually um I
mean this thing if we take that thing
you know it's going to do the right
thing right but that's a completely
different kind of activity than the
color one because the color one is
hard-edged correct
you're either in the neighborhood or
you're not it's not like this thing
where there's in a sense this is like it
can be soft-edged you know and for the
application asking right but I think
Stephen is both crisp and soft edges are
interesting actually right you know it's
so soft edged and masking gives you
greyscale presumably yes okay so but a
replacement has to be it has to know are
you in or you out
it can't be well we're sort of partly in
right right so please don't have these
things I have giant essays on the right
hand side like this just have something
simpler and then explain them afterwards
sure okay
why don't I like neighborhood somehow it
just reads very strangely you know color
neighborhood have red
I mean colors around red would read
nicely
comments what is the default distance
that same nuclear DNA mLab
no no no I mean how far out if I just
say : neighborhood of red how far out
does it go
do I get to orange or not well you get a
little orange but no why not not too
orange itself I think it's a point two
or something like that it's still a
fairly small okay so how does it relate
to human perceptual you know color
distinction if we want to be
perceptually correct
we need an automatic distance depending
on where in their space VR okay that
sounds highly useful highly useful
so I mean that is in that is a color
distance setting of which of the color
distances is the perceptual distance is
that the CIA 76 one yep okay so I mean
to me that should be the default here is
a certain distance that is for I don't
know the you know I don't know whether
the the hypersensitive double X
chromosome you know whatever they are
more cone cell folk um you know I don't
know ignoring them you know the typical
[Music]
you know there must be some standard
color distance that typical people can
distinguish that should be our default
for this function make sense
okay okay so
okay okay let's try another possible
name approximate color
no how are the generic wrapper
approximately red almost red
you
how could that possibly work I mean are
you saying
the I mean you're saying almost four
comma point two means
uh you know within point two of four
mm-hmm so you would say something like
this I mean that is sort of interesting
to be able to do something like that
I mean that would be more like you know
unfortunately almost it's a bad word for
that I mean that's more like an interval
thing and we certainly don't support
that right now although it's an
interesting idea to have some kind of
interval replace like within yeah I mean
I think these are all reasonable ideas
um let me uh since we don't have anybody
we have nobody from project management
here is that correct
seems like it really shouldn't do this
without okay um okay but but but I don't
think that's gonna work for the I mean
that that's a that's a bigger you know
fish to fry to have some general notion
for arbitrary spaces of you know the
hard-edged
you know ball within that distance so
here by the way question comments on the
livestream from from Flip Phillips about
n-dimensional color spaces like hexa
chromatic spaces apparently do we does
our color system it does in principle
support that because our images support
any any any number of what am i saying
any any number of channels right
do we support these other colors places
we don't support them but yes our image
is super then and dimensional Audrey
arbitrary n dimensional channels and is
there anything about our clearly you
know even with CMYK as somebody who's
pointing out on the livestream that's a
four dimensional color space right um
and we do support that don't we
we have CMYK wait I understand but I'm
asking in color distance for example are
we supporting the four dimensional CMYK
color distance like if I say color
distance between two CMYK colors what
does it do no it's converting to
whatever color space the distance is
defining so if you're talking you don't
get more colors just because you have a
different parametrizations right and
CMYK as you well know sold a particular
rendering problem for printers you know
what you don't get more actual colors
that was just sort of like a device
setting that was useful for printers no
I'm aware but if you print in you know
if if you you know there's six color
printing and all that kind of thing yeah
well where you've got more basic colors
and you're making things out of more
colors sure and you can get further into
the blues and all that kind of stuff
right but usually we you know there's no
okay
PDF and adder which are sort of printer
driver languages of modern type they
have pretty sophisticated colors
overhead certainly the CIE spaces and
all that so you're not restricted to RGB
or anything that is a little bit limited
that means that if you have a printer
that is six color printing that is part
of the responsibility of the printer no
I understand that to those six colors
for opt
you know it's optimized but before our
purposes when we are measuring color
distances does it not matter you know in
other words the color distance in a six
dimensional color space is always going
to be different than the color distance
in a three dimensional color space oh
look they can still be valuable like the
attacks are chromatic okay maybe it's
particularly convenient to parameter
some things in that space for some
purpose Europe but but further on the
device side I don't think it's it's not
it's not particularly interesting you
know I understand getting the device
output it's its responsibility is to go
from an RGB like there could be an RGB
color specification that is outside the
region supported by a display that has
you know it's just presumably assist a
triangle or something that is the region
of the chromaticity diagram that display
with three things supports with three
primary supports and we'll be adding
more color spaces for sure we need more
for video we have other ones we mean for
visualization all right okay that's not
a low cost thing to do but we want to do
nine is ten but let's let's loop back to
this issue this issue is what do we call
the the you know the potentially hard
edge the potentially soft edged you know
colors nearby you know what do we have
what's another place um where we have a
similar kind of thing can we have
anything in geo that's like this but we
have a notion I mean in geo we obviously
have geo disk and notice that geo disk
well I don't actually know how geode is
geo disk
yeah geo disk is the actual distance on
the surface of the earth I assume yeah
so under different projections it
doesn't actually look like a disc right
exactly right but but this is a
different thing because this is a
different metric an actual different
metric in the space right so it it
include different colors based on
different metrics no I get it but so
what's the right thing um and it so
happens like for this the recolor
function imagery coloring mm-hmm it's
very useful to pick the perceptual space
because that's what you can see first of
all oh and it's very useful to make it
soft because then then you really can do
to sort of make your shoe from red to
blue type thing in yes in in images okay
all right fine so so hold on so we've
got I'm still trying to verbalize why I
don't like color neighborhood well it's
not perfect Steven I agree with that I
didn't feel it was perfect but we kind
of struck out and I'm it so that's what
is a neighborhood a neighborhood
neighborhood is a simple it's a simple
region so neighborhood is topologically
equivalent to a ball you know it can't
yeah it can't have tears and holes not
or things in it you know and it's full
dimensional and so yeah so it's not
necessarily a ball you know as a sphere
a ball as you think of those simple
shapes but it can topologically it's
equivalent to that but but the triangle
disk oh go ahead would know whatever
shape you have you know a triangle is a
disk in that sense yeah look disk is not
going to cut it okay we've got a higher
dimensional space it's just stupid it's
forget that idea so I wonder if there's
something more informal that I mean okay
so color approximation I don't like that
it suggests the wrong part of speech I
mean what do we think of
approximate color we have another
suggestion from line live-streamed color
proximity the problem with that is that
it suggests it is not a noun
I mean the proximity you don't say the
proximity of my you know house is
whatever the proximity around my house
that would be it's asking it's more like
a question color subspace I don't think
that makes sense because there are just
too many that could be such a big you
know a color subspace could be just like
forget the red type of thing I mean
that's it that seems like a bigger kind
of thing um what do we think about
approximate color because that would I
thinking I'm thinking when you say
approximate it just sounds to me like
it's a particular one no no first of all
I the way I've said it already cheated
because I could say approximate color
right as opposed to approximate
adjective color right okay what do we
have what do we have for for numbers
that is I mean we have we don't really
have anything of the
type what do we have I mean like where
else do we have things that represent
something approximately we have it in
power series we have it in numbers I
mean we have a notion of four numbers we
are usually thinking of them as quite
precise so we might have a precision but
we don't have you know sort of a big
thing like that
no I just I you know if you saw a piece
of code that says um you know something
like color replace blah blah blah color
come a colour neighborhood it just seems
like what is this you know
I mean if you saw colors around more
colors near you have color near maybe
colors near
do we nearby colors nearby colors yep
that's interesting I mean that does tend
to suggest that isn't going to evaluate
it's just a thing I kind of like that I
mean the only thing that may be a little
weird is that it suggests not red but
only it's only things nearby well I mean
that can be gotten over is it a
punctured neighborhood or the natural
neighborhood
terms Hank that comes out everywhere you
know like limit wants a punctured one
and that's very important you know yeah
well okay colors near nearby colors okay
so the first thing here would be the
default case will be nearby colors bow
we've got a bunch of noise on a audio
could be try to fix that then
you know so the first thing would say
nearby colors of color would say you
know represents
colors
perceptually
indistinguishable
um
[Music]
from blah blah blah from that color
something like that
ah some flip Phillips is suggesting ISO
chromatic and some yeah cute but I think
it's a correct term but right and he's
referring to the book color for the
sciences I have a copy of that book
someplace - yeah riemann metrics on
color yeah I remember some of that stuff
it's very cool um there's actually an
interesting example of you know people
if you're trying to understand the
Riemann tensor and all that kind of
stuff or you're trying to understand I
mean the the no doubt there are
interesting examples here I mean this is
no doubt there are anyway look I think
nearby colors is quite nice
[Music]
and I think then here okay so let's take
a look at what that would look like
nearby colors
of red comma point one now you've got to
be able to give oh oh what a mess you've
gotta be able to give the space that
it's in right mm-hm and then you've got
to say whether it's hard or soft or
smooth or whatever right I really this
is CIE so there's no point in giving the
CIE whatever it is until you've given a
distance right um so I mean one
possibility maybe it's too grotesque is
to say something like um
something like this I mean the distance
here is always going to be a string name
is that true or no you can specify your
own function okay well so that could be
a function there or you can have an
actual distance function which gives
that right and why do you want the cut
off method hard smooth to be a part of
that distance specification mobiles I
think it's sort of related I mean you
suggesting it's a fourth argument or
something yep but you see if we do it
this way then that if then the case with
the default which is the default is CIE
76 is that true mm-hmm so then we could
get away with just doing this to
represent smooth smoothing around that
is there a default where there's a
second argument missing and where it's
just smooth or not sorry what do you
mean okay so it's we have it for example
if I would say color detect of
it should be nearby colors or colors
nearby I might prefer colors nearby so
let's still colors the color detect in
the image colors nearby red or we could
say color replace image now if I'm not
mistaken one thing we could say is
colors nearby red arrow green or
something but that by default will take
any color near red and map it into pure
green right right and now the new
imagery color is adding methods for
doing brightness preserving and so forth
replacement that looked like with that
scene by red so this this would make
image for color replace more useful but
it would still not be useful enough if
you're here I'm saying I mean it might
the other use cases for that what you're
giving there on screen now by the way
the live stream Ethan black 86 suggests
colors near and I think you're right
that colors near colors near
you
you know why not why not
nearby is silly there's no reason to say
nearby because what it is is colors near
you know I like that anybody object to
that not me me yeah sounds good um okay
so let's go through this again so in the
case of color replace when you're doing
make my red you know my red hues turn
into not huge but you know red reddish
things turn into greenish things what is
the specification for that is it red
goes to green or is it colors near red
goes to somehow colors near green color
replace can only do reddish goes to
green to pure green I understand that
but you're saying you want to add
methods to make it go reddish goes to
greenish that right we tried that and
the conclusion was that we introduced a
new function imagery color okay fine
okay so that can do reddish - greenish
yes and now does it say how does it
specify that so Karen see you so for the
input colors you specify it with now
colors near red and then it gets
whatever components of the color from
the target color so if you say I want it
to be say brightness preserving it
preserves the brightness but replaces
the chroma components of the color okay
I understand that but I'm saying in the
specification imagery color does it look
like this does it say colors new red
arrow green it has some separate option
that says actually I don't mean pure
green I mean you know green ish with
certain things preserved is that right
exactly
yes seems okay alright let's come back
to the specification of colors near and
okay so colors near red comma and now
this putting in the smoothing thing in
here is kind of weird because ultimately
what you're trying to do that is to say
color color detect of this and you're
trying to determine whether color detect
it's going to give you a hard edge at
the edge of the you know of the of the
you know nearness ball or not right
right I agree that that probably is
gonna make more sense for color detect
not colors near I think so because I
think colors near is like it's a it's a
bin and you can still say so so what you
need is some kind of skin depth for
something to colors near and you want to
say over what skin depth do you want to
do that gradation is that correct yeah
but it's some okay so
[Music]
so how would you want to specify that
that that's part of
I mean you're not specifying you
specifying distance - D what the heck
where there's a hundred there where the
head to the hundred come from I mean
this is some really bizarre arbitrary
wake function
it's arbitrary yes so to me a better way
to do that would be in color detect how
would you do this I mean color detect
there's one thing that it's just that
the the ball of colors you know near red
and the other is something where you are
trying to go I mean I would have thought
you want to have some decay function
also blend other pixels
what do you mean rather than the region
of interest as in okay so look look the
question is does this have a what does
it look like is it that everything in
the colors near red is precisely
replaced by you know is precisely
becomes the the white or whatever you
know Valley one and then there is a tail
outside of that which has a certain skin
depth or do you want to start having
values other than one even inside the
ball that correspond to corresponds to
colors near red currently that
proportional thresholding method is
actually doing the second thing you just
explained even within the ball we are
proportionally recoloring okay so it has
nothing to do with the the the nearness
distance is merely you know being
provided sort of for your your sort of
hacking in that the ball size is going
to be used to determine the exponent
right because it really isn't I mean go
ahead I think you see it there's a hard
boundary right in the color space okay
so that's the first case hard yes okay
now the question is if you want to make
that soft in various ways and also
they're two proposed I don't
particularly like the way it's written
up necessarily but the two proposed ways
of doing it softer you know one is
proportional which goes inside outside
and day one the other one goes
Chekov Lee outside only right right so
that so then I was right in my my claim
number one I think that in case what
you're calling smooth here it is in your
de color detection any color that's
within the ball gives one yep and colors
outside the ball gradually decay off to
zero correct and that one indicates
awfully fast yes right so so we've got
these different cases so I mean what is
the analog of the grayscale version of
detection for other things other than I
mean like edge detect doesn't have a
grayscale gray scaling option does it
have what are the other detect functions
like I mean in principle they could have
gray scaling that is you've got your you
know your hard edge and then you could
put sort of grayscale around that hard
edge maybe develop a lot of polarization
functions could take that yeah for sure
right I mean in color quantization maybe
no maybe not no no wait
how can binder
wait a minute binarization is trying to
binarize things but you're saying well
actually it's not binarized it's great
scaling well when know they are
currently all binary Singh but I'm
saying when it comes to using that
binary segmentation as a mask often it
doesn't look good if you just stick in
the binarized mask as the Alpha Channel
or something it's very common to want to
blend or smooth a little bit so how do
we do that in general do we have a
mechanism because it sounds like we need
then something which is a soft mask so
to speak currently we just blare if you
want it smooth it out we just blare that
binary mask okay but then the basic
bottom line is we don't have a general
mechanism for this and we're trying to
put one in for the color case correct I
think we need a more general mechanism
we have some things in threshold which
takes the soft thresholds as well that's
probably the only thing I can remember
now what is what is the function called
threshold no that's that's an option
right yep that's a function oh my gosh
do we refer properly between this and
shouldn't this be in like all our
sigmoid functions and things should
refer to this shouldn't they right it
probably should but they were they were
introduced afterwards right sedation yes
okay so that's another item please
somebody somebody note that down or do I
get to do that I had no idea gets that
though we can send it I'll be send it to
Sushma and I LP all right I think those
functions are mostly came from the
machine learning team like the the ramp
function for example should certainly
refer to threshold and I don't even know
what some of these all these weird
things in threshold actually are oh boy
all their pictures of them and they're
they're common thresholding where are
the pictures
if you go down I mean they weren't we
didn't do it back then I don't see any
pictures
I don't died her actually right now this
should be there should be pictures that
would be very useful okay so any of this
threshold thing could in principle be
done for the color stuff too couldn't it
except your soft
I mean your thing called smooth is yet
different from any of these and I'm
making sense
nudists yes you know we were too helpful
in this meeting that this would be the
last because I'm running into another
thing I have to go to let's just see
here oh boy um you just asked here um we
might be able to go up for a little
while longer here let me just see if I
can push back the next meeting um um
okay good all right so so I'm not
convinced here so I mean it looks like
that there are I mean couldn't you
implement any of all of these kinds of
things I mean you you really need some
kind of it seems like you need some kind
of arbitrary I don't really understand
how that's gonna work so you get this
soft mask here and then what you can do
with it so I'm saying I mean our other
functions don't take soft masks like
that image functions we have masking
supported in many functions no I know
but it's a hard mask in zeros and ones
isn't it no we do accept grayscale masks
as well okay okay look so the question
then is here how does this relate to the
many different thresholds that you might
use you know why are you picking this
particular one with its weird hundred in
it
I admit that's arbitrary we can change
it just gives a quick transition from
the region I realize it gives a quick
transition I mean I can see the hundred
that the question is that how far do you
want to go from the region well yes
right and this seems to have things with
parametrized you know I mean in general
this function threshold seems to be a
thing that would
um yeah and that's really weird okay I
agree we should at least come up with
parameterised smooth method hard
wouldn't have any parameters
proportional doesn't need either but
smooth I agree we can have proper
settings right these are all functions
these are all pieces of color replace
I'm sorry yeah the color detect no
imagery color and color the detect color
detail now is gonna be the one that
returns the mask a grayscale mask all
right let's try to hit if we can I think
there's a little bit more thinking to be
done here and I think we're going to
have to come back one more time for this
okay but I think it's colors near is
good solution thank you to folks on the
livestream involved in suggesting that
let's try and hit for one second image
pyramid apply okay okay um see if we can
then also we have yeah maybe we should
do that but I was thinking of the the
audio stuff we have Karl earlier yeah
we're not ready to deal with annotations
yet we are not ready no no I know not
the annotations I would suggest we do
that than the other meeting later but
yes okay but you're talking about audio
identify no short time for you stuff
well I thought we've come to a
conclusion there or did we are you now
that conclusion
yeah so the problem is that there are
different things okay so a spectrogram
has half the data that a short-term
Fourier transform I am aware yeah okay
so when you want to I still think your
idea of having the Gram function in
particular right now spectrogram return
an object that happens to display as a
graphic but then can be computed with
and we can try to reconstruct the
original signal we can still if we can
still call it inverse spectrogram
but it's not a tree inverse sure I'm
saying no I and it's not okay let's let
me go through this but once and for all
try to understand this if you have a
real function a real signal and you take
its Fourier transform you end up with
this doubled thing right
oh am i right I mean is it is it as pure
so in other words if I were to take
what's a good way to make some random
signal I don't know some some random
walk how do I get some Roger how do I
get a nice random walk process do I do
that no what do I do
I don't you have to look at there I
can't remember I don't use this every
day let's look it has documentation I'm
aware
you
you
okay all right well this is going to be
a mess
to do this this way um can I do afraid
transforms that hmm right should be it
that should work can we make a note of
that unless you can swing with it okay
so here we've got this thing might be
wrong because it involves also a time
stamps which for there is no happy with
I think further adjustments the buttons
okay whatever okay do I need to make a
random walk myself instead of using
normal you get the values you do someone
on the live stream is is very kindly
sending us a function here for okay
we still need values our values of this
okay all right okay so if I say Fourier
values of that no alpha goodness sake
what am I supposed to get is this a
property it's a property of temporal
data I know Y values doesn't work on it
but anyway that should probably work too
okay all right let's just do this I
would have been able to compute it
myself unless time okay anyway no you
wouldn't
yes I would I would have just declared
vina process no I'm not proving it
process okay right so anyway so I've got
free a here and now I can say blah blah
blah let's say I say let's line plot ABS
of that okay fine
all right my question for the math folk
here is what is the relationship I mean
is this if I take a real signal
originally are these two sides a naive
math question what are these two sides
identical or not
conjugate I'm sorry I'm so value is the
same okay fine so are you telling me
there's no new way is that can there if
I have a real signal is it true that
there's no new information in the second
part of the Fourier transform yes
correct okay if I had a complex signal
there might be new information is that
correct I'm not entirely sure no more
anybody else no Roger do you know yeah
there would be him okay fine
okay so spectrogram is of real data
therefore the fact that you're only
displaying half of the Fourier transform
in the spectrogram is not losing
information yes value is yeah you only
have the absolute value okay what it
says that is the half of the things you
plot here it's reflected around the
point where your mouse is so the
absolute value the second half for the
absolute value can be reconstruct from
the first half yeah yeah I get it I get
it I get it I get you lost the phase
information yes right okay
I get the point yeah I understand the
point and Anna spectrogram you know
could one imagine I'm just asking the
question
Coburn imagine a spectrogram where
there's some hue for the colors that
represents the phase information I mean
right now we have a color intensity that
represents the energy at that you know
in that frequency time but they also
that spectrogram is its many Fourier
transforms one for each segment if
you're sure I'm saying no I understand
that but what I'm asking is will you to
color with a hue the spectrogram in
addition to giving the intensity I think
that's not called us back to how many
more but it's not a spectrum you know
but I'm just trying to ask just truly
understanding if if we had that human
formation would that be enough
information to you know store would that
also store enough phase information that
we could uniquely reconstruct yes that
you need that here we are not studying
the absolute value so yeah unfortunately
only
one at a time you know what way to sing
waves and wins it but a spectrogram as
we draw them right now is not in color
so to speak it's alright so this is just
the this is not a speculum as what Arjun
was saying before this is just one frame
of a spectrogram what you do with the
spectrum is ya know in this operations
on partitions of data no I I got that I
get that I get that I know I understand
I'm saying that I'm asking you the
question ok so if I make you know if I
do
you know if I say this hello there and
then I make a spectrogram from that
anchored when clearly could you know so
right now it's it's showing the
amplitude there as a intensity okay
right yeah the only one could code that
up as a color for instance you can only
display one time either the intensity of
the phase if your way of displaying it
is an image and the color that presents
the value Y this is color intensity here
I mean this could be look the fact that
this is in yellow is just decorative
this could be grayscale and I could have
you know the phase is what I see color
and brightness yes okay I'm correct in
saying that phase is a single number
right yes it is at each point yes so in
principle I could have an enhanced
spectrogram in which I see the phase yes
indeed yes if you hue and brightness
yeah as long as you can display some
things that each point that's fine right
actually some are only on the live
stream is pointing out the hue would be
good because it has its its periodic
just like the phases yep right um okay
so were we to have an enhanced
spectrogram we could have an inverse
spectrogram that would actually work yes
so the thing that I always try to point
out is that that is not the definition
of a spectrum is that you take the
absolute value and then I get it a
square of it
yeah I get it I get it I get it but I'm
I mean I'm just trying to understand in
principle I would have a spectrogram
okay so here's a here's a way we could
make this work I'm not saying it's a
good idea but we could make this work
that when we ask for spectrogram the
thing behind the scenes is an object
that contains phase information maybe
this is a stupid idea but it's too much
data and we don't need it and so on but
then we could faithfully get an inverse
spectrogram from that behind-the-scenes
thing even though the display would only
display the absolute value we went down
there and the thing is yeah I realize
you want that okay and but it seems like
there are plenty of operations that
could be done which are so it's muddle
things that's the Pring okay
I think short-term Fourier transform is
the thing that is the full data that's
the full data case it's a well known
thing I know I know there's nothing
wrong with having short-term Fourier
transform like a short time Fourier
transform I don't like object to that
good but I do object to having that
return some kind of weird data container
well it's gonna have to do that yes why
it needs all the parameters yeah so what
I don't it just a car loan it said about
Fourier as well now really just returns
alone this is like one parameter okay
yeah there are window size window offset
a window function okay this is no it's
just second so so your point is using
Fourier is comparatively easy because
all you need to know is one number using
the output of short time Fourier is
difficult because you need to know a
bunch of numbers in order to be able to
do that reconstruction exactly okay
although mathematically I could use I
mean we went through this before there's
some Association that gives I mean short
time for it needs to have a second
argument that is an association of these
things like window
it is window size and so on correct it's
just it just has essentially the same
arguments of spectrum not not a single
item including Association okay but but
what you're saying is you want as a
convenience to the user to have which I
don't think is a community I think it's
a mess to have the output being some
packaged object that also contains the
information on how it was made and you
could say that for a million other
things that you could want that I mean
for free a you could want that as well
but it's much more convenient in that
case just to produce the list you can
then operate on with generic list
operations rather than producing some
weird object that has to have its own
set of operations and where you know we
fail to implement a bunch of those yes
I'm not convinced I mean if you want to
do something if you've got a short time
Fourier transform and it used particular
window sizes blah blah blah then you can
and you say well I want to do something
I want to invert that now I've got to
use the same window size well you know
you should still have that association
lying around that gave the window size
just use it to do the inversion so I'm
saying
I mean you know part of what you're
assuming is that you'd never want to do
an inversion with a different window
size that it's always wants to be a
thing where this is merely another
representation I'm not getting it I did
you know the data object there is
backing this out you can modify the data
inside it and that includes some of the
parameters window size of course you
cannot really change because it was
really you're making my argument for me
I mean you're basically saying don't
store go ahead yeah so the advantage is
that you can do your processing on the
data but then the container still keeps
track of all the other parameters I know
that but but you still have that
information I don't like the idea of
having another container I don't like
these very special purpose containers I
think they cause us a lot of trouble I
think we're better off the
you have to keep track of the you know
the how it was made information and feed
it back in when you need it
rather than have it carried around in a
container but I want to come back to the
finger I think is much more useful here
which is this notion of a spectrogram
that you can operate on yeah I think
that that's a pretty useful idea and I
think we could then apply actually the
same idea to the other Graham functions
like what him well
septa Graham periodic Graham yeah I'm
less familiar with those but yeah I mean
I know yeah but okay so let's come to
this question about phase information
okay um so you say that there is is
there in particularly in modern times is
there in fact a reasonable sort of
pseudo inverse like thing that you can
do yes there are phase reconstruction
arguments and a couple of them are
implemented in what currently is in
virtual time for you okay okay and it
would be better that those go away from
there they go into inverse spectrogram
because the two operations are different
one is an approximate reconstruction and
the other one is essentially a perfect
reconstruction fine all right so so then
what you are I mean let me make a crazy
suggestion right that we actually have a
function called we could have a thing
called phase spectrogram maybe that's
better name for it which would be this
color I don't know if it's useful is it
useful is a phased spectrogram useful I
have seen it several times so someone
evidently uses it I don't know they uses
it the users of it
I don't you find out whether there's
some I mean I just have no sense of
whether that's something that comes up a
lot
I just not you know phase is not
something um yeah I guess I don't really
we don't explicitly tend to sense plays
I guess only implicitly so it's good for
like phases good for the tape detecting
things that change abruptly so there is
one thing I'm sure there's no okay well
let's let's look at that but in any case
so there's a possibility of some kind of
phase spectrogram phased spectrogram
maybe I'm not sure that that would be
the colorized version or alternatively
it could be some kind of option to
spectrogram and then as the question of
do we behind the scenes when you make a
spectrogram do we make any attempt I
mean to store the phase information or
not and is that a method option so I'm
saying I mean we could have a method
option such that spectrogram will store
the phase but not display it or not
store it and not display it so the
Nimbus spectrogram in that case would
need to do phase reconstruction makes
sense so the question here I guess I
could look at what you just said if your
computer a spectrogram then you have the
original data later on why would you
compute inverse so the point is can you
do some kind of processing on this this
short time from your data allows you can
do processing and then invert it but if
it's a spectrum object that just this
place as a graphics I'm not sure how you
know that's the whole point the whole
point is to have spectrogram be a thing
which displays as graphics but which
stores the data inside it and the
question is does it store the phase data
or does it only store the intensity data
right so what would be some operations
you might do I mean I think you should
be able to do a bunch of audio
operations on the spectrum and I think
it's very convenient to be able to say
you know do you know slice up the audio
do this that and the other tag the audio
you know etcetera etcetera the question
is still why would you do these
operations on the spectrum rather than
the original signal especially since
most of these operations are natively
applied so you would have to
transform it back to a time domain
gnosis it and then go back to the short
time Fourier domain well I mean there's
certainly some operations like pitch
you know pitch shifting which could
easily be done on a spectrogram directly
yes on yes it's yeah the complex
spectrum let's say not right yeah okay
but so okay I mean look as a convenience
to users it's clearly the case that if
you are displaying the spectrogram and
you want to think about your audio in
terms of spectrograms you know you could
yes you could go back to the audio and
then say slash slash spectrogram at the
end of every line right
yes but it will be nice to be able to
just do these operations directly on a
spectrogram object it's like doing them
in the frequency domain or something
yeah the problem is that for most of the
most operations there would be a lot of
wasted computation okay because you
would have to do this domain switch
multiple times okay that that's the only
value compared to just undoing the
operation on the audio object let me
remind you one of the reasons we want
inverse spectrogram and I hadn't really
internalized this phase reconstruction
business okay if you are trying to sana
Phi something let's say I've got some
picture of a turtle I don't know what
black and white picture of a turtle okay
and again it may be totally crazy and I
haven't you know really had experience
with doing it but imagine that you view
those pixels as like a score you know a
spectrogram ie I mean a spectrogram is
sort of a a representation of a score in
some sense if I'm not mistaken there
well kind of yeah except for the fact
that it's I mean which a might be much
bigger gun there's more than guns
additive but yes sure
and the other difference is by default
at least it has a linear scale it does
not have a can you make
spectrogram does it make sense to make a
spectrogram with a lot is actually one
of the most used features for like
neural networks ml spectrogram so well
the y axis is aligned with the mel scale
which is a something that mimics human
perception not exactly pitch but still
not linear okay so can we do that in our
spectrogram there should be an option
I'm not sure if it was merged already
I'm not sure okay I mean mostly if I am
to you know in the inverse spectrogram
case and again it may be crazy but it
seems like people want to do this kind
of sonification method of you know I've
got this score like thing now generate
audio from it yes so actually this is a
platform I've got this core like thing
let's generate audio that that's kind of
like just it's not something that is
overly it's interesting but not overly
so now they think that well this is used
a lot and is super useful is for example
you have a neural network the outputs
that they strain on spectrums and
outputs spectrograms
just real values and the phase needs to
be reconstructed and this is because the
neural networks is huge and you can
really try it on something with multiple
channels in that case a lot of a lot of
neural network has post processing
functions something that does this
inverse operation so in that case it's
actually crucial for real world
applications so okay and that exists
already in inverse in in web time for
year and as Roger was saying it probably
should live outside it and have its own
exist in its own right something that
takes real data and then outputs a
signal okay so fine so what you're
trying to convince me of which you may
very well be right about is given a
spectrogram or one of these sort of faux
spectrograms without phase information
generate from it not a spectrogram oh
yeah okay fine you're just saying we
need a function that given something
which is equivalent to a spectrogram
generate a signal from it right yeah
which is what we have been calling him a
spectrogram yes and yes I thought we had
lost time we had concluded that what we
want is a function that will take
essentially lists of data we'll take a
data array and treat that as a thing
that is like some kind of spectrogram
and have the parameters to just take
that data array and produce meaningful
you know meaningful sonification of it
yeah so what I'm trying to convince you
of is that yes we should have this
perspective Amodeo function of inverse
spectrum or however you want to call it
but shortened version painfully and
short and for a data have added value
independent of this and they are fairly
separate problems and I'm look I'm
convinced that short time frame makes
sense what I'm not convinced about is
the container as I say okay I see okay
but I think unless proven otherwise that
it is a bad idea to introduce a new
container and that it's really if you
want your thing to be sensible you have
to carry around somehow the you know the
thing that you use to make it you know I
think otherwise we otherwise again I'm
so I said this multiple times here
otherwise we have to make a hundred
functions support you know various kinds
of managing of short time Fourier
transforms so I understand the point now
the way we thought we would kind of get
around the fact of of creating 100
functions to deal with short include a
transfer data is having essentially
properties that you can so you can
if you're short time for your data
object is s you can say s data equals
low pass filter of s data that's an L
value not a chalice no okay I mean
that's even more crazy that the number
of things we have to support if it's
gonna be an L value is even larger um I
mean yeah the problem is there isn't a
free you know you might say oh isn't
there a framework for just introducing
things that have L values and this and
that the other well the problem is as is
so often the case there is actually no
free lunch you can't you know these
things actually have to be done in
detail for each case because they're
actually different and it's not
something where you can generically say
oh just introduced no value I mean there
is there is a framework the one that
Callie came up with so I'm aware of that
ya know where but it's not the right
that's only the beginning of the story
for something which is the operational
function like this it's one thing to
have something like persistent value
which is just a storage mechanism anyway
look it sounds like
unfortunately we really have now run out
of time it sounds like we have some path
forward although there's more to be
thought about about this inverse
spectrogram thing but I don't think that
necessarily inverse pledge program is
the right name because really what it is
is you know it's more like yeah I mean
like reconstruct a fire I was thinking
that you would be able to come up with a
well I'm thinking spectrogram audio
which is what we talked about last time
Oh which takes
like it takes a random data array it's
got to be given certain parameters that
say okay this is the data array like
what are the rows of the data array mean
right like so let's say I got my bitmap
from a score effectively write the rows
of my data array in that case mean no no
I understand you're just giving in a
different name to to endure spectrogram
I think so because I'm are we missing a
case now or isn't there like a data case
for spectrogram and now I can't get the
data case out there's only getting audio
out for which for for spectrogram
doesn't it take just raw data as well
it does yes right so now I can't do the
reconstruction to raw data I can do
reconstruction to audio but I can't do
we care yeah I'm not sure I'm not sure
um I think we do care actually we have
run out of time I really want to you
know the other thing we got to do is
that image pyramid apply and and I'm I'm
really distinctly you know that's
another one of these things that has
some crazy um you know where you've got
a crazy rapper object now boy I need to
understand this better
I mean your basic point with image
pyramid is this is a representation of I
don't get this at all I I'm sorry I just
don't get this I don't understand why
image pyramid isn't basically just an
alternate representation of an image
just like image data you know you've got
various ways like interleaving goes to
true and false and things like that
um and right so there's different ways
of representing the um um
livestream participants I appreciate her
enthusiasm was suggesting that I cancel
the rest of my afternoon but I can't do
that I'm going off on a trip on Monday
and I've got a whole bunch of things to
finish so unfortunately I really have to
go to these other ones which are also
important um Roger can you I'm sorry
this is a this microcontroller kit
review what roughly is that and okay so
this is the elevator speech this is the
ability to generate embedded code that
runs on micro controllers and micro
boards as opposed to distinct from the
Arduino link mechanism right which is
just sort of remote control of slow
things this actually downloads and runs
code so if you need to run a controller
like yeah I get it I get it right okay
no processing those kinds of things that
need to actually run live you know fast
even if it's an 8-bit controller okay
all right I get it okay sadly I have to
go here I'm sorry and I appreciate them
but but I just want to make my case just
for one second it's really really late
here that image pyramid is in a sense
merely a representation of an image what
the solar transforms right what is you
know what's Fourier transform it's a
merely a read representation of the
function
right there yeah Lu decomposition
it's a merely a representation of the
matrix so happens to be useful right
fair enough yeah but so Lu decomposition
we actually currently return as a list
of matrices right
yeah well that one is odd for various
reasons but that's a long history going
back to 100 or something okay but in
that case
yes you here is okay you know is the
image pyramid when you want to do things
with an image pyramid is it that you
want the pieces of a pyramid out or is
it anyway we'd I'm sorry we need to go
long right okay
to be continued and okay so sadly we you
know I'm gonna be out for a couple of
weeks if more of these are scheduled I
can try to join but no promises okay
well we might be able to do it on Monday
before I have to get on a plane getting
on the plane in a couple hours
oh you are okay okay well yeah so much
for that well let's see whether we can
schedule it at a time when when you will
be around then um okay and okay great
maybe we'll even livestream that the
thing about microcontrollers unless
Roger no okay but let's plan on doing
that so people who are into this if you
want to hear about microcontrollers that
would be at let's see it would be about
just under just about two hours from now
so thanks to everybody on the livestream
much appreciate your input and talk
you'll soon